my reps were so nervous because it's
it's such a big deal can you believe
that one of these actors is over double
the age of her character and did you
know that Joe Kiri was kicked out of the
stranger things group chat for being too
old join us as we shine a light on the
truth stupid idea
scary thing to attempt number one he may
be the cool Big Brother on stranger
things but not so much in real life
jokiri plays 16 year old Steve even
while he's 26 and if you're wondering if
his younger co-stars look up to him as
much in real life as they do on screen
Joe revealed in an interview with Access
Hollywood that many of the child stars
keep in touch through a group chat but
that he was kicked out for being too old
number two the youngest March sister
wasn't all that young Florence Pugh was
cast to play 12 year old Amy in Little
Women when she was 22 in real life they
could never go home again because I'm in
such trouble far from seeing this as a
problem Florence said in an interview
with Indie wire we forget that Amy is in
that sweet spot of nearly looking like
an adult but being a total child and I
think every single woman has been in
that situation where they are probably
12 but they could look 14 15. number
three it was probably for the best that
he was replaced by Tom Holland Andrew
Garfield was brought in to play 17 year
old Peter Parker for The Amazing
Spider-Man when he was 27 and although
the characters High School graduation in
the sequel may suggest that he was 18
Andrew was actually 30 during filming in
fact when he was approached to do
Spider-Man no way home eight years later
he almost turned it down because he
thought I'm far too old to be playing
Spider-Man now but they they asked me
back and and it says the sweetest thing
ever number four just because you've
grown up doesn't mean you can't go to
Hogwarts Shirley Henderson was 36 years
old when she portrayed the child ghost
Moaning Myrtle on Harry Potter and the
Chamber of Secrets who's moaning Macho
this was an intentional Choice by The
filmmakers Who felt that any aging the
character did between films would be too
obvious if she was meant to be a ghost
and so they thought that casting an
adult with a more youthful look would
provide a sense of agelessness when she
returned in the Goblet of Fire number
five sometimes it's better not to ask
questions apparently the creators of
never have I ever didn't even know
Darren Barnett's real age when they cast
him to play 16 year old Paxton Paxton
hollushida is our Dream boat every teen
show has to have one as co-creator Lang
Fisher explained you can't ask someone
how old they are when they audition you
just have to assume that they're a
reasonable age it wasn't until they were
already deep in the season that Darren
revealed he was actually 28 years old
which Lang replied with oh okay number
six it's getting harder to believe by
the year when Cole Sprouse was first
brought into play 16 year old Jughead on
Riverdale he was 24 and while his care
character continues to be a sophomore
Cole is now 27 still he says that he's
grateful for the role for being able to
transform him into a leading man in his
20s while moving away from his former
Disney star image now it's our turn
it's our time number seven Jughead isn't
the only casting Choice who's a little
too old on Riverdale I
mean
the Ashley Marie was 29 when she first
took on the role of 16 year old Josie
McCoy and she would continue to play her
well into her 30s still Ashley felt that
she could relate to the character
despite the age difference saying I
don't know how to explain it more than
sometimes when you read a role and you
know it's you number eight Chase Stokes
is the oldest actor playing a teen on
Outer Banks John B might be 16 on the
show but in real life Chase is actually
27. in fact he even admitted that he
didn't try as hard in the audition as he
could have because based on the
description his manager had given him he
assumed that the show was Netflix's
version of The Goonies being far too old
for that he thought he didn't even have
a chance that is until he received the
script and I was like a giant mistake
this is not the Goonies it's it's
literally not the goons number nine if
you've read the books you may remember
Daenerys as being 13 years old The Game
of Thrones series on HBO decided to age
her up to 15. although you may be
forgiven for not noticing considering
the actress that was cast to play her
Emilia Clarke was 24 when she filmed the
first season the show's creators
explained how massive the role would
have been to someone younger stating
young actors aren't often asked to play
a combination of Joan of Arc Lawrence of
Arabia and Napoleon
number 10 it's a pirate's life for
Orlando Bloom although he and Keira
Knightley were both playing 19 year olds
in the first Pirates of the Caribbean
movie she was only 17 while he was
actually 25. funnily enough though over
the course of sequels Orlando actually
would Age alongside his character in
Pirates of the Caribbean Dead Men tell
no Tales Will Turner is supposed to be
42. while Orlando Bloom was 40 at the
time of filming
look at me son
number 11. did you know that Rachel
McAdams originally wanted another role
in Mean Girls she may be the perfect
Regina George
I know right but originally she had her
sights set on Lindsay Lohan's role when
director Mark Waters saw the 26 year old
actresses audition he felt that she
looked too mature to play the ingenue
but said I think it makes sense if
Regina kind of grew up a little too fast
even though Regina is also supposed to
be 16. number 12. a younger look doesn't
have to be a bad thing princeyarisa has
spoken quite openly about how she
struggles with how young she looks on
camera admitting that I obviously wanted
to graduate into playing older roles at
the age of 29 she's still playing an 18
year old on grown-ish it just
it sucks though she's also said that
she's learned to embrace her more
youthful look and to appreciate that I'm
able to participate in shows like
gronish because I do look so young
number 13. can you even imagine being in
high school this long Ross Butler was 27
when he was cast to play 17 year old
Zach on 13 Reasons Why saki you coming
no I'm good brother don't eat it after
four seasons the then 30 year old actor
would say that he's ready to move on
stating that I've been growing out the
facial hair I'm ready to hang up all the
jerseys and all the sports I've played
in fake high schools since then Ross has
moved more into the production side of
the industry which is something he says
he's always wanted to do number 14
sometimes it's just part of the job
although Bianca Lawson was 31 when she
took on the role of 16 year old Maya on
Pretty Little Liars she said that she
didn't have too much of a problem being
able to relate to her the way she
described it she's always considered her
yourself a good enough actress to be
able to relate to any character
regardless of age stating it's not
necessarily the age of a character I've
done so many Supernatural characters
that were like 106 years old you know
what I mean number 15 16 as if Stacey
Dash was actually 28 when she played
Cher's best friend Dion from Clueless
woman why don't you be answering any of
my pages I hate when you call me woman
Stacy went on to joke about her age
during a special screening of the movie
in Los Angeles ahead of its 20th
anniversary saying I was 27 and I was
playing this High School student I have
a son at home who is six years old still
Stacy would go on to reprise the role
throughout her 30s in the Clueless tv
series that ran from 1996 to 1999.
which actors's real age were you most
shocked by and how well did you think
they did in the roles don't forget to
make your thoughts heard down in the
comments